[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirklich das
herrlich vom ST Galla Rheintal nach
Florida zieht es
Familie am Golf von Mexiko wollen sie
Ferienhäuser
vermieten zuerst aber müssen Sie
renovieren
[Musik]
fast am Polarkreis liegt das neue zuuse
von Isabel Schelling und steef
Felix in Island suchen Sie mehr
freiheitir auf ihrem riesigen Grundstück
wollen sie tiny Häuser
bauen
in dem Bereich stell die
ein schön
findet bin so stolz
sch und sein Partner gabock übernehmen
auf der spanischen Ferieninsel Mallorca
ein
Restaurant gibt viele
Arbeit beginnt so jetzt siehst du
ungefäh wie viel Schaum ist bis hier
soll das Bier sein ne warte warte
wartete
ne W guten
Appetit ein traumhafter Blick in S Galla
Rheintal das Eigenheim mit großem Garten
und
Swimmingpool Familie charna hat das
wofür Sie viele beneiden okay dann le
das ja
trotzdem zieht es sie
[Musik]
weg seit 8 Jahren Träumen Melanie und
ihr Mann Mario vom
Auswandern wow bist du
hübs
wow ihr Sehnsuchtsort die USA
hab das ganze Elter wirleit über ja das
Amerika Fans sie das die Faszination vom
Land die Faszination von der L denn halt
ja Musik meine Mama so Elvis
[Musik]
Fan zurück zu der Wurzel ja so Gefühl
her
auch Mario ist vom amerikavirus
infiziert bei ihm begann alles mit alten
Autos
Achtung mit seinem Oldsmobile 98 hat er
sich ein wenig vom amerikanischen
Lebensgefühl in die Garage
geholt W hen sch recht viel erlebt
mitand schon fast gehört sch fast zum
Inventar oder zur Familie
nicht nur das Oldsmobile steht jetzt zum
Verkauf auch von ihrem Haus sowie allen
Möbeln wollen sie sich
[Musik]
trennenier
ja
Melanie und Mario fahren mit ihren
Kindern zu einem USK Treffen ein letztes
[Musik]
Mal die Veranstaltung ist ein mecker für
Amerika Fans und für Liebhaber von
blitzendem Chrom und
Stahl
coolterel ein stad in Oldtimer
investieren Sie Ihr Geld zukünftig in
Immobilien in Florida haben sie bereits
zwei Häuser gekauft diese wollen Sie
renovieren neu ausstatten und an
Feriengäste vermieten oder
weiterverkaufen so ihre Geschäftsidee
jaol s Melan Leidenschaft neben ihrer
Tätigkeit als selbständige Coffs
verkaufte sie shabby
schickmöbel mario hat einen kaderjob und
verdient damit den Großteil des
Familieneinkommens das einzige Angst
macht al vor allem mir oder finanzielle
oder das da immer sch aufg Monat und
auch wenn es gut lauft h D den so
Pension und so so schöne sa du mus musst
selber
oder trotz der Unsicherheit der Plan zum
Auswandern
steht V8 und viel Li und Geld investiert
aber
jetzt Verkauf also h wirklich sehr
spezielles Auto wenn
das
ist das da der nein das
ist und und das und das sind alles so
Ring sind noch nicht ganz ganz fertig ja
in wolfenschießen im Kanton nwalden
bereiten sich zwei andere Auswanderer
auf ihr Abenteuer vor ste Felix und
seine zukünftige Frau Isabel
Schelling
die beiden verpacken Steffs Werkstatt
hier widm sich Steff seinem Hobby der
Holzschnitzerei
so ja gen
klein isab und Steen nach
Island
g
genau
jaal oder was ist
al und S mit
All und wenn die sind
Wasserfall lau sind to sch sind überall
überall und ja zum Glück zag
freutolich und
ins könen mal erkundigt und das hat dass
wir d immer wieder gegangen sind ja und
eigentlich ja für auch nur das Land in
frag zum wirklich
auswandern in Island wollen sie tiny
Häuser bauen und diese an Touristen
vermieten so bring sie da hinten aber ja
so me Hof D
einfach ja anders
Klima Distanz zu der viele l
das ein alles auf und ab einfach
so ja sehr viel
Luft und und auch einfach eig Projekt
starten Traum erfüll dass wir wirklich
eine
gemeinsam ja
bau trumstte
ja mit Häusern kennt sich Isabel aus
seit über 20 Jahren arbeitet sie in der
Immobilienbranche Steff ist gelernter
Steinmetz sein Geld verdiente er jedoch
vor allem als
Eventmanager ihre Jobs haben sie
gekündigt der letzte Arbeitstag liegt
hinter ihnen alles geht nur noch in eine
[Musik]
Island auch ihr großes Haus in hergisv
hat schon einen Käufer
danke Plan geschickt
[Musik]
ja für den Bau der Tiny Häuser wollten
sie einen Generalunternehmer aus
Österreich beaftragen so der Plan doch
jetzt ist alles
anders
war wir in österich zum Vertrag
unterschrieben für die erste hü und
inusbauussuchen
alsolich komplett
alles Plan und vor vi tagsag
dass Baumaterial nicht h
vusland also Holz nicht das heißt
Projekt ist momentan in nicht
durchführbar ja und Problem ist BAB in
Island gemacht mit den
Hüser F einfach jetzt no mal anders h
wir müssen wieder
von wochenlang hatten sie verschiedene
Haustypen begutachtet und Anbieter
verglichen mit der Firma in Österreich
glaubten sie den passenden Partner
gefunden zu haben durch die Absage droht
alles zu plat
[Musik]
ja im er Moment so na ja DF nicht W oder
und ja mir Moment ist halt einfach ein
lehrie und hätte ein ge Moment braucht
ja ist für natürlich Existenz od W
aufbauen heiß ist für natürlich
entscheidend das Ken aufbauen oder
[Musik]
nicht
hochdf im Kanton Luzern es ist kurz vor
Mittag in wenigen Stunden wird
Filialleiter OTM gemperi diesen
Arbeitsplatz ein für alle Mal
verlassen der letzte Arbeitstag ja sehr
komisch es komt ein gar nicht so vor al
so der letzte ja no alles erledigen und
nachher he wier machen
ottm zieht es nach morca dort möchte er
ein Restaurant
übernehmen die Verträge dafür sind
bereits gemacht in vier Tagen geht es
los den
hochorf vom Supermarkt im Luzerner
Seetal zum eigenen Restaurant auf den
ballaren mit 18 mal auf morca mit me
Mami Z mal und se bin ich eigentlich im
Jahr me me viermal in mayor so eig die
ganze Insel erkundet und bis ichig meine
Lieblingsort gefunden oder besser gesag
Lieblingsort mit me
Partner und wir haben wirklichort
verliebt und wenn das
ne und ich meine ich in der Schwiz 15
Jahr Gastronomie erfah K mit damalige
Partnerin sie ist immer sehr gern mit
ferie
aber laben und geschaffte h sie sich nie
könen vorstellen aber ich eiglich Traum
eigentlich nicht los und W jetzt Traum
[Musik]
l noch ein letztes Mal frische Ware
bestellen dann ist Feierabend
[Musik]
zu Hause in
Emmenbrücke OTM wohnt in einer
viereinhalb
Zimmerwohnung zusammen mit Mini
Chihuahua Ronaldo und Partner Gabor
ballock alles gut
ja
ja Ronaldo Papier sindarat am Montag kan
ichol Reise
Papier Gabor kommt aus Ungarn seit 7
Jahren ist er mit OT
zusammen auf Mallorca werden Sie nicht
nur zusammen leben
S auch gemeinsam arbeiten in M
Lokal morgen schon kommt der Zügelwagen
sch vol du m was nimmst du für fürise
KOF Tasche ich nehme nur
meine
Gasse das schwarze das ist
kleiner der Traum von das passt mir auch
ich habe auch immer so geträum irgendwo
leben gibt und Wasser und vor allem in
kleine Insel und das ja freut mich auch
dass wir können etwas selber machen so
meine unsere Business und
ja passt voll oh mein Gott so viele
Sache da haben wir alles irgendwie gich
nicht Fred und glücklich ich w wieder
selber selbständige Betrieb obwohl ich
weiß was das heißt wieder selbständig Z
und was das vom muand aber ich weiß noch
die 15 j w ich selbständig s ich befner
gen ja und mir hoff jetzt mir das
gefunden was man
z
ja für den Traum vom Leben im Süden muss
OTM Abschied nehmen von Emmenbrücke dem
Ort seiner
Kindheit Familie h das Gästebuch gemacht
für das Restaurant wo
über und da war das Ziel immer wenn zu
mit dass das Album wier geführt
wird ganz schöne
Idee weiß schon genau wie er sein
künftiges Restaurant auf Mallorca
gestalten
will bringen modernisieren das Brune das
wird noch goldig geht so Akzent wo der
Bar eig mit Goldlack gemolt wird da im
Hinterbereich D attraktiv wird also die
Besitzer mit und dann Personal wo sch
Insel ist wird
unterstützen ja es ist Hal e volles
Risiko also ich wirklich alles was ich
nicht für das Projekt
investiere und ist schon wirklich
[Musik]
jaation
Strom der
[Musik]
turbineelp
Mario als technischer Leiter ist er Chef
von rund 20
Mitarbeitern heute zeigt er einem
Lehrling und zwei neuen Mitarbeitern die
technischen
Anlagen dreieinhalb Jahre ging der
gelernte Elektroinstallateur hier ein
und aus ist nun bald
Geschichte das wird mit zum der schlüss
auf
geh die wunderbaren
Anlage
passt
wirlichü Mario möchte raus aus der
Routine und in Florida etwas Eigenes
aufbauen die alteat der ist sowieso als
digital immer
auf schön
gemacht mit und das F den George
Island l
ganz 17 oder 18 wei
nichtau auch zu Hause in Gams stehen die
Zeichen auf
Abschied bevor sie in die weite Welt
ziehen haben die charnas noch einmal
Freunde Bekannte und Nachbarn zur
Poolparty
[Musik]
eingeladen
Kaffeemaschine
[Musik]
Kaffe danke viel ist Spruch wo drin bist
aber erst in
Amerika büess
trinken meladyis Freundin Andrea hat zum
Abschied ein T-Shirt
entworfen K alle im teaml FL fahen genau
wir Flügen mit dem
T-Shirt
ja Hand vor wo B schwanger mit dem mit
dem zweit
spga und
komisch ja es
ist
Spielplatz gen schaffen schaffen dason
für ein Nachtessen in EUR neuen
[Musik]
Heimat
ja amerikanisch oder servel Salat und
Bier Schweizer Gemütlichkeit im Kreise
von Freunden und
Bekannten nicht mehr lange dann kann
Familie charna zum Baden ins
[Musik]
Meer am vierwaldsttersee ist die Suche
nach einer Lösung für die tiny Häuser
für einmal
[Musik]
Nebensache
gut Isabel und steef wollen heute
heiraten
okay das nicht und ja irgendwie hat sich
S so über die Jahre erg und ja irgendwie
stimmt jetzt einfach für mich mit Isabel
scheint alles zu passen die gemeinsame
Begeisterung für Island die Lust auf ein
Abenteuer und der Mut das Projekt mit
den Tiny Häusern
umzusetzen gut se Jahre ist es hier dass
sich Isabel und Steff über eine dating
Plattform im Internet kennenlernten in
Island machte er ihr den Heiratsantrag
am Diamond Beach versteckte er den
Verlobungsring in einem
Eisblock ist ein perfekt sind ganz alle
Strand ist wirklich kein Mens und das
sind Hal so die schö isblöck Strand ich
B da das ist auch noch ein schönne und
dann bin ich
solor
und eigentlich den überhaupt richtig
begriff mich den schon sehr überrascht
also das ist wirklich gelungen besser
sich nicht
könen dann ist es soweit im Kreise der
engsten Freunde wollen sie sich das
jahrwort geben herzlich willkommen sind
Sch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nervö jetzt a Zeichen von ihrer
Verbundenheit und ihr
[Musik]
lick malelle
trage
Kopf
also ich l überrasch ich weiß nicht wo
Gott keine ah nein keine ahn eine
Überraschung von Steff für Isabel als
Hochzeitsgeschenk
ja Nein Helikopter
ja frisch vermät zum Rundflug über die
alte Heimat
auf bgerstock
herch
[Musik]
schön absolut nicht
ja einfach das kann fast nicht kaufen
das ist einfach das
Glück danke
[Musik]
Schatz und solandisch SK a SK
SK früh am Morgen in Emmenbrücke
kan schnell was du V der Jacke her auf
dre we W noch kleiderschachtel zu also
das kannst Du schon
einpacken
pulloverovere ich zügelunternehmer Alex
soll das Hab und Gut der Auswanderer
nach Mallorca bringen
also die
Z ja
Element das kann ich
machen ja
okay
okay ins neue Leben müssen fast 100
Kisten mit persönliches aber auch viel
Ausstattung fürs Restaurant kann nicht
so gut gchlafen ich kan n alles
Kopf ja wir erledigt Hand ja und dann
vielleicht so z D Stunden ja danke schon
geschlafen nach bin ich wieder
wach der Umzug undter Schritt ins
Ungewisse scheinen otma zu belasten
Wehmut macht sich breit jetzt wo es
losgeht machen wir Tür nicht zu kleben
nein machen wir
allesado willst du auch helfen was Mast
ja
und das muss unbedingt be dem
djzug dass man das wieder so
Abladen ja ich ma DJ Schlager
DJ
verschied Deut Schlager schwezers
Schlager partymik berallerman Musik
ja
zum einem Hotel in England gearbeitet
gab ja h
bitte soll ich noch raus ja und einfach
Alex sagen das ist Bildschirm drin
einfach aufpassen Computer auch alles
hier ja der 20 Jahre ältere OTM ist der
Planer Gaber hilft wo er kann er macht
auch aber muss ih immer sagen muss im
sag komm mach
rter du ja komm helf
Schatz wo hast du deine hauschlüssel ich
muss das nachher suchen also bitte jetzt
Brau
OT muss die Schlüssel morgen an den
Vermieter
zurückgeben wir haben vielleicht
eingepacht ich ma nicht na bitte sch
vielleicht wir haben ein Paket
reingemacht me ich weiß nicht
mehr fast alle Kisten sind schon im
Lastwagen aber wo ist der
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Schlüssel doch
dann in der Schmutzwäsche wird er fündig
a zum Glück danke
sonst hten wir Pech
oder der Zügelwagen ist bis auf den
letzten Quadratzentimeter
gefüllt wir haben es
geschaff alle unsere Sachen drin gute
[Musik]
Reise in wenigen Tagen wollen sie den
Transporter auf Mallorca in Empfang
[Musik]
nehmen auch bei Familie ist es soweit
die engsten Freunde sind mit ihren
Kindern zum Flughafen
gekommen du länger geschlafen als
du nur stundeschla und
du
in wenigen Stunden fliegen sie ab nach
temper in
[Musik]
Florida sechs Mal schon waren sie in den
USA in den Ferien diesmal gehen sie für
immer Meister eigentlich obwohl alle im
sagen Kind werden sich schnelleren als
mir wird W der Fall aber so jetzt der
Moment fühle mich so
richtig und es ist sch Herzschmerz
ja sie fliegen einmal quer über den
Atlantik
meh voresorgt
vergessen wasserfest Mascara ich
vergessen
danke
Ciao ma
gut gut 8000 km trennen Familie bald von
der Heimat und ihren
[Musik]
Freunden
normal
[Musik]
bereitst ist das letz mal
ja im denk ja ja sinden sicher noch und
no und jetzt ist wir let mal
[Musik]
ja ha
tschüss Ciao
[Musik]
min
die forgotten Coast ein weitgehend
unberührter Küstenabschnitt im
Nordwesten
Floridas vor 9 Jahren haben die charners
diese Region auf einem Roadtrip für sich
entdeckt
[Applaus]
nach einer Nacht im Hotel in Temp sind
die unterwegs zu ihrem neuen
[Musik]
zuause
fre
ja lad und der Grill
chmeißen so richtig schön wieder das
Heiz irgendwi
juhu jetzt z wir den
GRA dieses Mobile Home ist für den
Anfang ihr daheim vor ein paar Monaten
erst haben sie es
gekauft
so so jetzt sind wir da juhu rtiger
schwim in den letzten Ferien haben die
chas begonnen das Haus zu
renovieren da soust
da das ist ja alles dreckig war
dreckig nein der joh hat doch Dach neu
gemacht oh was h du ke
[Musik]
Wasser während ihr Abwesenheit waren
Handwerker im Haus und haben das Dach
repariert
alles Badzimmer das Wasser
lau
schei
SP
[Musik]
Spal sie die Wasserrechnung zu
begleichen GEW im
sch doch alles halb so
wild die Zuleitung war abgestellt für
den Fachmann kein
Problem
vol
alligatore Schlange
ja
Delfin ganz viel
tolle das nicht so Angst also wenn der
soll direkt ins gebüch langangen nur D
wo sie wirklich gesh dann kom das auch
gut
extra
mal
lieblingsfarbwis so
jetzt
bet Betten bezogen Fleisch auf dem Grill
und Wasser da die Ankunft im neuen Leben
scheint bei Familie charner
[Musik]
geglückt auch otma und Gabor sind
inzwischen in ihrer neuen Heimat
Mallorca gelandet
ja das sch mal Ciao
Alex und Sie bekommen schon News vom
Zügelunternehmen mach's gut ciao ciao
tschüss Transport ist alles gut er ist
in Barcelona oh er ist jetzt er geht
jetzt F buchen und wird nachher Morgen
um 7 Uhr sollte er hier sein das ist
schön die beiden sind unterwegs zu
Corina der bisherigen Inhaberin des
Restaurants
[Musik]
ja grüß euch
Hall bra ich keine Angst haben fürs
erste kommen Sie hier unter zusammen mit
Hund
Ronaldo ja schon ein wenig
langsam
zmer die Wohnung der Saison für ihre
Angestellten erstmal bis ihr dann eure
Wohnung
habtz hier verbleiben dan gut gut tip
top ich habe als kleines
willkommensgeschenkt Danke sch ein
gastronomisches Wörterbuch damit ihr
auch schon gleich dann ja deutsch
spanisch englisch französisch
italienisch damit ihr dann auch schon
gleich ja für den Start ein bisschen
lernen könnt schön danke viel mal
bitte der nächste Morgen noch befindet
sich der Ferienort kalarada im
Winterschlaf aber schon in wenigen
Wochen kommen die ersten Touristen hi
Alex willkommen mit dem Tageslicht
trifft auch das Hab und Gut der
Auswanderer
ein schön
bist der Plan war dass wir eigentlich
mal alles in dem Bereich denblade und
vorsorti für die Kisten wollen sie
vorerst im brisas delm Lagern ihrem
zukünftigen Restaurant 10 Jahre lang
führte Corin das Touristenlokal während
der nächsten Monate soll sie es nach und
nach an
MA übergeben so haben sie es vereinbart
wir machen die Pflanzen hier unten dass
wir hier genug Platz haben zum
ser nach
unten oh
sorry jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was das
alles ist
OTM wird als Chef vor allem hinter dem
Tresen
stehen wo machen wir das drauen ja schon
mal da Gabor ehemals Krankenpfleger
Hotel und bckerei Angestellter soll im
Service
arbeiten ich hoffe nachher die
Restaurant ist auch so voll einfach mit
Menschen oder das hoffe ich auch ja
hier die Ecke oben
drauf und dann so in die Ecke dass man
stzpunkt hat
hallo Europ das ist
der Vertreter von Europ die haben alles
was so Brot angeht okay also wenn ihr
inf Katalog online hier auf der
und also man kann auf der Webseite auch
die Sprache auswählen
[Musik]
Perf hast als Abschied sagt man oft so
anstatt tschüss sagt man so as also
heißt offiziell bis später aber das wird
einfach so sehr viel
benutzt okay das kommt schon
noch wollt das alles in die Wohnung
[Musik]
transportieren fertig Hochzeit zurück
auf dem harten Boden der Realität
Isabelle und ihr Mann Steff sind
unterwegs ins
bernbeat trotz intensiver Suche haben
sie immer noch niemanden gefunden der
Ihnen die tiny Häuser für Island
produzieren und auch dort aufbauen
kann einefundeno das produzieren
Verschiffen no aber nicht aufbauen und
das W wir nicht wir W ke suchen wo das
baut und jetzt haben wirutech Termin da
hat eentlich Interesse dass er das wird
produzieren verschiffe und dann bauen
selber gerade Frage ob prieslich
einigermaß im ren bliieb das ist
eigentlich eine von der letzte Notnagel
wo wir da
H
[Musik]
durch den Verkauf Ihres Hauses haben sie
zwar ein gutes finanzielles Polster
trotzdem ist Ihr Budget begrenzt grüß
Frau Felix
gr
herzkmen Holzbauer Heinz B hat viel
Erfahrung seine Arbeit aber auch ihren
Preis jetzt bin ich gespannt
was sicher einige Frage S
große h da da noch das kommt da der Teil
ja und nach kom näch kleine wird den da
drauf und da draf h der architekte schon
so Situationsplan wo we Hüs ST macht
oder noch nicht das meh mal so das war
sicher gut WN ich das maßst
hat Mast braucht das auch nicht also
Isländer braucht es nicht das ist
unglaublich ja gut was ich mE jetzt
wasb
die eineinhalb Stunden
später ja ja ja ja ja
ja schwierig ja also ichke D alles gut
und recht und alles aber schlusseffekt
ist einfach finanzielle
also ir überallesusbauen und so aber
aber
wirklich dass es
finanzielld ich momentan
frze trotz Lichtblick Isabel und Steff
müssen
[Musik]
weiterbangen auf und davon beginnen gab
und
mit der Arbeit Sie renovieren zusammen
mit Corina das
Restaurant gucken ob das jetzt passt im
Keller des Lokals jedoch ist das Chaos
größer als
erwartet W das büroichten aber das so
schlimm ist ich nicht
wirklich ja das
ist Winter anstatt Sommer in
Florida
Familie wird von einem Kälteeinbruch
überrascht und
Dach sie wollen so schnell wie möglich
raus aus ihrem Mobile Home und machen
sich auf
Haussuche der Familie in der
Schweiz mit Sack und Pack brechen isab
und ste nach Island
auf F machen das ist
[Musik]
speziell
у
бо
е